do you think that trans women should be
allowed to competing in women's sports
no I think a lot of people are so work
that there's an old hip-hop head myself
I know that there's no such thing as a
typical route to being a rapper but if
there were use wouldn't be it tell us
about your story about how you ended up
making the music okay sure thing so um
my story starts way back so I was born
in the UK I moved to Saudi Arabia with
my family when I was very young and
lived there and went to school there for
a while before coming back to England I
went to a boarding school here for a
while I went to Oxford University I
studied computer science while I was in
university I started rapping just began
as a hobby to begin with I released my
first album when I was in my second year
of university which did really well and
then after I graduated I did my music
full-time for about a year moved to
London worked in the corporate world for
a couple of years whilst juggling my
music stuff on the side and then in 2011
I took the big plunge and I've been
doing my music full-time ever since yeah
but there can't be many rappers we've
had a previous career in the city of all
things can there aren't that many I am
aware of a couple I am aware of a couple
I don't know if you know I think he's
not a rapper but I don't know if you
know John Legend used to work for I
think Boston Consulting Group where a
few other rappers who have worked in
investment banking and things like that
so it's a typical but um it is possible
you know I always people often joke
about me going to Oxford and getting a
degree from there and then going on to
become a rapper but um I always say you
know a degree is to open doors not to
close them now that's none of this is to
say that you're not political um with
your music and indeed with you with your
own views you once described yourself
remember reading this and I think it's a
great is the Jordan the Jordan Peterson
of rap and that was that was all to do
with a tweet a video that you did just
tells the story there I posted a video
of me doing a two hundred and thirty
kilogram deadlift
around 500 pounds or so and in the video
I said something like um the caption was
I keep hearing about how biological men
have no advantage over women in 2019 so
watch me destroy the British woman's
deadlift record without trying and then
I wrote PS I identified as a woman
whilst doing this lift so don't be a
bigot and the video went crazy
they got Scott almost approaching 1.6
million views now it was covered by lots
of national news lots of international
news that may well have been how you
found out about me it went a lot further
than I ever imagined or predicted at the
point when I tweeted that from my phone
so the response to it as yeah the
response to it has been been crazy but
you seem you seem to be making a
political point when you said you know I
a PS I identified as a woman reward what
are your views on trans polity is that
an trans experience is that political I
think it was just making a rather
obvious point that lots of other people
didn't want to make which is that
biological men and biological women are
different that shouldn't be that
shouldn't be a controversial statement
and any sort of saying world it's
something we're all implicitly and
explicitly aware of and do you know that
everyone knows that the reason why
sports are sex segregated to begin with
is because males are stronger and faster
than females are on average especially
once you get to an elite level there's a
very large performance difference so do
you think do you think that trans women
should be allowed to compete in in
women's sports no I don't and I think
that anyone who's aware of biology and
isn't being driven by ideological and
emotional factors would agree with that
what do you mean by ideological factors
well if you've gone through puberty as a
male I mean if neck even if I went on a
hormonal treatment for one year I think
to bring my testosterone down to a
certain level and then I went and I did
actually enter a female powerlifting
competition next year or say Anthony
Joshua in boxing transition to a woman
and next year and was boxing okay
biological women I think you'd have to
be either stupid or you know
ideologically possessed to think that
that would be remotely fair because it's
not there is a strength advantage
there's a speed advantage there's a body
size difference and we're we're all
aware of this so I think it's I just
think it's fairly it's fairly clear-cut
I think that's something people know but
because of the current climate a lot of
people are afraid to say that because
they fear the mob but so I was just
making a point
it was obviously rather tongue-in-cheek
but um I think the reason it resonated
so with so many people was just it was
like okay finally somebody is pointing
this out so to what extent then would
you respect the wishes of a trans person
to be identified to be spoken about in a
certain way in terms of gender pronouns
we're going back to the Jordan okay yeah
sure in terms of just politeness and
being kind to people and not going out
of my way to offend people just like I
generally don't you know I don't want to
it doesn't matter who I'm talking to I
try to treat every human being that I
speak to with respect and you know I was
raised to treat people as I wish to be
treated so that's fine I think from I
think the concern this is the thing that
you know Jordan Peterson raised up with
a bill c16 in Canada the concern is when
it starts affecting laws or in the terms
of sports like regulations and things
where there's actually a direct
potential impact where you're forcing
something on other people I'm very much
a live and let live kind of person so
but I think as soon as it starts
encroaching on stepping on other
people's toes or forcing other people to
accept things or believe things and it
doesn't matter what that's about I think
that's when society a free society
anyway runs into some issues given all
of that and giving you a young
articulate black man what do you think
about a topic of conversation that is
arising a lot more often these days the
idea of reparations reparations
even in the u.s. in the US and what
remember them in the UK itself had had a
major role within the slave didn't it
for a long time people have argued in
the past but it's about time that we
paid our debt I think people just need
to move on I think it's good to
acknowledge history and it's important
to be aware of the mistakes that have
made been made in the past and but I
think also it's important to not dwell
on them and that that's from all sides
okay so nobody who's alive now in the
Western world they're there's minor bits
of slavery that still exist but you know
that we're attempting to stamp that out
but generally speaking nobody was a
slave nobody owned a slave nobody's
parents even were slaves or slave owners
or anything like that I feel like I mean
what people we should draw a line in the
sand there and move on and also from a
actual point I mean even if someone did
make a case for it it's not tenable to
actually implement mm-hm
so if you take the USA for example where
that would probably be the best case for
it how on earth would you even calculate
who is owed what and who pays what
there's no feasible way I think that
would it would really be done I think
certain politicians are talking about it
as a political tool to you know gin up
votes in certain communities but I don't
know I'd like to see how they would
propose that it actually be implemented
I don't think it's tenable you must
still be aware that there will be there
would be American Americans you hear
usage a of course it is you know time to
move on who point out that slavery and
the absence of the same civil rights as
white Americans are so central to their
black identity that it's almost
impossible to move on to box it up and
put it to one side and and ultimately as
you're suggesting forget about it yeah
I'm not even saying forget about it I
mean you can acknowledge something that
you couldn't know I mean the thing is if
you're going to talk about slavery how
far you're gonna every race of people
has been enslaved at some point in
history and every race of people has
enslaved people in history I think when
people talk about slavery they always
think specifically about slavery in
North America mmm-hmm but I mean the
word slave itself comes from Slav so
from Eastern Europeans so there have
been white people in slave there have
been Arabs and
slave there you know and it's I think
part of that conversation is because
people view it in such a narrow lens so
if you were if you were going to really
go back and do that you'd have to really
look at everybody everybody's history
there will be black people who you'll
find who their ancestors were slave
owners and we're selling slaves and
you'll find Arab people in the same
situation you'll find white people whose
descendants were who are descendants
from slaves and so you'd have to expand
the whole conversation to millions and
millions or billions of people and I
don't know how you'd find out who it was
what does it at all concern you that
let's just confine this entirely to the
world of music that there will be those
who suggest what those who are surprised
by the fact that your rather less
inadvertent commas walk than the
majority I think a lot of people are so
work that they're asleep
I think there's almost two separate
definitions of woke now I mean there's
one level where it basically means being
ideologically possessed by some of these
ideas which doesn't strike me as meaning
what woke should and then there's like a
layer below that where someone realizes
okay some of these things don't really
make sense or are not good ideas or are
not tenable or some of them even are
directly in conflict with each other for
example I use that I think of promoting
culture multiculturalism whilst claiming
things or cultural appropriation so if I
make sushi I'm now culturally
appropriating Japanese people but at the
same time you're saying oh no I should
embrace Japanese culture and cuisine
it's like well which which one of these
things is it if you're gonna take a
whole bunch of people from different
places in London or in New York at any
any place where you've got a whole bunch
of religious ethnic racial whatever
diversity then people are gonna you know
things are gonna people are going to
influence each other things are going to
rub off on each other I mean I'm a
rapper
hip hip hop was created in New York in
the 70s so our British rappers
culturally appropriating Americans are
Chinese rappers German rappers are only
Americans allowed to rap I mean how far
do you go and I mean I remember the
first time I really heard this phrase
cultural appropriation was actually in
relay
to Eminem when I was a teenager that was
the first time I really heard that
phrase cuz there was there were people
claiming that Eminem was culturally
appropriating black culture and hip-hop
and whatever and I remember even at that
time being a little bit puzzled by this
idea of you're saying well you want all
that you want everybody to participate
this is an art form that's created and
everybody can participate it's inclusive
and then someone who's outside of a
certain box wants to get involved and
now you want to demonize them for that
and it doesn't make sense
hey there are even a few Scottish
rappers these days of course there are
as there should be
instead CD many thanks for joining us
here what I did